me llamo suleimán alza acá tengo 23 años
vengo de homs en siria y ahora vivo en
berlín
berlin
sulaimán y su familia lograron
refugiarse en alemania en 2014 después
de perderlo todo huyendo de la guerra
lograron reconstruir sus vidas y
abrieron una pastelería siria en la
capital alemana sulaimán trabaja allí
varios días a la semana
antes de llegar a berlín ya teníamos eso
por objetivo
aunque en ningún caso queríamos ser una
carga para los alemanes o vivir de los
subsidios de desempleo
ahora que son dueños de tres pastelerías
se hicieron un lugar en berlín pero ese
éxito también los ha hecho blanco de la
extrema derecha en repetidas ocasiones
aquí pintaron el símbolo de la ss y aquí
incendiaron una camioneta que
estacionada frente a la pastelería
ataques que dejaron una huella profunda
en sulaimán
antes de venir pensábamos que alemania
era un paraíso luego nos encantamos un
poco aunque aquí estamos bien
pero uno pensaría de verdad que después
de la segunda guerra mundial este tipo
de cosas ya no existen según parece no
todos los alemanes cambiaron
a pesar de esta experiencia sulaimán
aspira a quedarse en alemania está
estudiando fisioterapia a distancia por
causa del cobi pero sueña con regresar a
homes cuando se termine la guerra
mi objetivo es algún día puedes regresar
a siria para abrir un consultorio de
fisioterapia
me gustaría ayudar a la gente sobre todo
a aquellos que sufren de heridas de
guerra
mientras suleimán espera a partir de
este verano encontrar un puesto de
fisioterapeuta en berlín y seguir
apoyando a la empresa familiar